since we got so many positive voicemails about
my interview yesterday with Michael Moss on
how people become addicted to food, in a sense,
and how a big food industry giants have a
role to play in that.
Here's a voicemail left on our voicemail.
Number two one nine two, David P..
Of course, the show is playing in the background.
That's almost a requisite for some of our
favorite callers know.
But we love this caller and he tells a very
interesting story.
Take a listen to this excellent segment with
the fellow from The New York Times, Mike,
the nutritionist.
Listen, I have the sea of using had a real
bad to go for some brief remarks on three
different occasions.
Yeah, I stopped your regular, you know, just
like potato chips and ice cream.
But recently I've used just baked potatoes,
oatmeal, fresh pineapple and bananas, bright
and serious and water and orange juice.
That's it.
And my brain has improved dramatically, very
dramatically.
And what he's talking about, you know, he's
one of those medicines on day three, but he's
so right on this guy.
Yeah.
Listen, this I heard from so many people and,
you know, a lot of these industries, they
they profit from complexity.
You need us to tell you what items should
be on your list of things you can eat and
things you can eat or hear is a bunch of super
processed products that are either kido or
vegan or whatever.
And you look at the ingredient list and it's
protein extracts and all of these different
reformulations of of elements of different
food products.
It's that's where all the profit comes from,
from making things complicated and from recombining
ingredients in a more profitable way.
And of course, different folks have different
food requirements and sensitivities and may
have lifestyle choices around food that they
want to make.
But the best thing anybody can do is get off
of the food products, buy ingredients rather
than food products.
And obviously people's lives get in the way.
And sometimes it's difficult to do this or
that or take, you know, home cooked meals
every day.
But the point is, the simplest thing is, oh,
you know, our sweet potatoes, good or bad.
No, I mean, just go with the most unprocessed
possible diet.
And that's what we continue to learn in yesterday's
interview with Michael Moss.
If you haven't seen it, check it out very,
very much.
Well reviewed by The David Pakman Show audience.
And I'm glad to hear our friend whose name
I forget, but I recognize him with the that
may be actually be a Providence accent.
I don't know that it's a Boston accent.
Good guy.
Glad you're doing better.
Glad the COPD is doing better.
OK, on the bonus show today, Twitter is backtracking
after an outcry for the gender neutral term
women with an ex WOMEX.
And I don't even know how it's supposed to
be pronounced.
I want to talk about this entire thing, particularly
when it comes to Latin X, which is something
I don't subscribe to.
And I have an interesting story to tell you
guys about.
When will the mask wearing safely stop?
We're going to discuss that on the bonus show.
And we're also going to talk about a way that
Democrats, without killing the filibuster,
could gut the filibuster.
All right.
All of.
Those stories and more, I will be joined by
producer Pat on today's bonus show, sign up
at Join Pakman Dotcom to get instant access.
I will see you then.